and you should see the horrible things
that Tuilaepa said about Israel and a RC
plus three that's what I call it ALC
just take a OC plus three and you should
see the things that the four of them
have said about Israel over the last
couple of years
I mean Omar is a disaster for Jewish
people I can't imagine if she has any
Jewish people in her district that they
could possibly vote for and then
yesterday I noticed for the first time
to leave with the tears all of a sudden
she starts with tears tears and I don't
buy it I don't buy it
I don't buy it for a second because I've
seen her in a very vicious mood at
campaign rallies my campaign rallies
before she was a congresswoman I said
who is that and I saw a woman that was
violent and vicious and out of control
and all of a sudden I see this person
who's crying because she can't see her
grandmother she could see a grandmother
they gave her permission to see a
grandmother but she grant standed and
she didn't want to do it
president from what is your question so
that's a decision of Israel that's not a
lot of people are saying that was my
decision that's a decision of Israel
they can let them in if they want but I
don't think they want to when you read
the things that they've said about
Israel how bad and if you look at their
right in early before they found out you
take a look at their itinerary that was
all going to be a propaganda to her
against Israel so I don't blame Israel
for doing what they did I have nothing
to do with it but I don't blame them for
doing what they did I think it would
have been very bad to let them men say
something yeah with just underline that
and I think it would be a very bad thing
for Israel but Israel has to do what
they want to do but I would not cut off
aid to Israel and I can't even believe
that we're having this conversation
five years ago the concept of even
talking about this even three years ago
of cutting off aid to Israel because of
two people that hate Israel and hate
Jewish people I can't believe we're even
having this conversation
where's the Democratic Party gone where
have they gone where they're defending
these two people over the State of
Israel and I think any Jewish people
that vote for a Democrat I think it
shows either a total lack of knowledge
or great disloyalty